There stands a good chance that Avengers:
Endgame might mark the final film for several
Marvel favorites, but in the weeks leading
up to the film's launch, the cast is keeping
their minds off such grim outcomes.
The Endgame press tour has been filled with
both laughter and emotional moments.
However, there's no escaping the fact that
the end is nigh, and that Earth's Mightiest
Heroes will face a dangerous fight in Endgame.
One member of the Endgame team who isn't letting
the rest of the cast forget that harrowing
reality is none other than Thanos actor Josh
Brolin, who has delivered a terrifying reminder
to his fellow MCU stars.
Taking to Instagram, Brolin posted a photo
of a set chair with the Mad Titan's name written
on it, plus the Infinity Gauntlet carefully
sitting atop the seat's back.
He wrote in the caption:
"When you all are done with all your interviews
and your talk shows, I'll slip this perfectly
fitting gauntlet back on and tell you a story
about your future."
"He's pretty good at that."
"Right?"
Just as Brolin's post hints, the Avengers:
Endgame crew has been incredibly busy promoting
the ensemble pic.
What they haven't been able to do during those
events is, ironically, talk about what's coming
in Endgame, if they even know themselves.
"I didn't even get a whole script to this
movie.
I don't know why.
The script I did get had dummy scenes in it."
Marvel is keeping an airtight lid on Endgame
details, and for good reason, as the studio
doesn't want to ruin the movie-going experience
for anyone or risk damaging what's meant to
be the culmination of 11 years of stories
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
That said, the interviews the Endgame stars
are giving are essentially hype-boosters rather
than detail-dishings.
In some ways, the lack of plot specifics and
the hesitancy to talk too much about Endgame
is a distraction from the inevitable: the
un-dusted heroes are all but guaranteed to
go head-to-head with Thanos once more.
Still, everyone knows that's coming.
The Endgame teasers, specifically the most
recent special-look trailer, point toward
the Avengers crafting a plan to take down
the Mad Titan, reverse his Decimation, and
resurrect the fallen heroes, plus the billions
upon billions of other lives that were lost
post-snap.
What that mission entails is a total mystery,
though.
A theory that has gained more traction than
others is that the team will gear up in their
new suits, which look kinda similar to the
one Hank Pym wore in the Quantum Realm in
Ant-Man and the Wasp, and travel back in time
to stop Thanos from ever coming close to getting
his hands on the Infinity Gauntlet.
Another notion is grounded in something Captain
Marvel said in the latest look at Endgame:
"So let's get 'em.
Use them to bring everyone back."
"Just like that?"
"Yeah."
The heroes may not turn back the clock, but
may instead remain in the existing timeline,
journeying through space to rip the Infinity
Stones straight from Thanos' hand.
Speaking of the Infinity Gauntlet, there's
also the idea that the mystical armored glove
won't be as powerful in Endgame as it was
in the final moments of Infinity War, which
saw both the Gauntlet and Thanos' arm suffer
damage as a result of the Snap.
The glimpses at Endgame we've gotten so far
hint that the Gauntlet is charred, and the
Russo brothers previously revealed that, quote,
"The power that it takes to use all six stones
is significant and clearly damaged the gauntlet
and damaged Thanos."
Joe Russo added during a Q&A session following
a screening of Infinity War that Thanos' arm
is burned, and explained that the damage extends
to other parts of his body, including anything
that's on his arm, like the Infinity Gauntlet.
Russo said:
"The physical price is the extreme power that
it took to enact his plan, he paid for physically,
and when he sits down on the steps at the
end of the movie you can see that it actually
carries up into his neck and onto his face.
His arm is f---ed up and anything attached
to his arm is f---ed up."
So even though Thanos will evidently slip
the Gauntlet back on and spin a terrifying
tale about what his vision of the future holds
for the heroes he didn't kill in his Decimation,
there's a chance that the damage he has already
done to the Gauntlet and to his own body will
throw a wrench in his overall plan, whatever
that may be.
Right now, the ratio of answered questions
to unsolved mysteries surrounding Avengers:
Endgame is pretty low, and no matter how hard
we speculate about what could happen in the
film, the only way to get the truth is to
wait patiently until the film opens in theaters
on April 26.
You know what that means.
"We're in the endgame now."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Avengers:
Endgame are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.